[Musique]
un nouveau variant de la covid-19 cause
bien des soucis et comment ça se
multiplier aux États-Unis et ben
malheureusement il a traversé la
frontière et il commence à circuler au
Canada est-ce qu'on doit s'inquiéter
donc de ce sous variant qui s'appelle le
xbb-1.5 on a notre grande spécialiste
Cécile Tremblay avec nous elle est
microbiologiste affectologue au Centre
hospitalier de l'Université de Montréal
merci d'être avec nous madame Tremblay
c'est un plaisir bonjour bonjour Alors
l'épidémie de covid flamba en Chine ça
on le sait on sait que les variantes
pourraient se multiplier aussi est-ce
que c'est le cas du xbb un point 5
concernant le Kraken sur les réseaux
sociaux qu'est-ce qu'on sait en fait à
propos de ce variant là en fait c'est un
Variant qui a émergé aux États-Unis mais
qui est présent dans 70 pays à travers
le monde on sait que c'est un
recombinant de deux souches de variants
BA2 donc on se rappelle le BA2 c'est ce
Marianne de Micron qui était assez
délétère et puis qui réussissait à
échapper notre système immunitaire
encore mieux que bo4 ou B A5 donc le xbb
1.5 lui
sa particularité c'est qu'il est très
très contagieux encore plus que celui
qu'on a au Québec présentement qui est
le bq.1 et puis qui encore plus de
capacité d'échapper à notre système une
table parce qu'il a une mutation dans la
région de son enveloppe qui fait en
sorte qu'il adaptent plus facilement au
récepteur de nos cellules donc c'est un
c'est un Variant dont il faut se méfier
qui va rapidement prendre tout le
terrain parce qu'il est plus contagieux
tout simplement que c'est ses ancêtres
bon je suis certain que les gens sont à
la maison en ce moment écoute tout ça et
ont une seule question est-ce que les
vaccins qu'on a reçu nous protège de ce
nouveau variant et des autres
en fait ce qui est intéressant c'est que
plus on reçoit nos doses de rappel
meilleur et la protection il y a une
étude qui est apparue la semaine
dernière dans le New jerusen qui a
regardé finalement le sérum de personnes
qui avaient reçu soit une dose de rappel
deux doses de rappel avec les anciens
vaccins ou une dose de rappel avec les
vaccins bivalents ceux avec le BA4 ou le
BA5 à l'intérieur et ce qui me constate
c'est que les gens qui ont reçu la dose
de rappel avec le vaccin bivalent ont de
meilleurs taux de neutralisation de ce
nouveau variant là donc c'est pas
nécessaire que le vaccin contient
précisément le variant qui qui circule
présentement mais plus on a une immunité
qui se développe contre différentes
sortes de variants plus notre immunité
devient capable de contrer de nouveaux
variants qui émergent donc ce que ça
nous dit ça c'est que ce serait
important que les gens vulnérables et
elle est chercher leur dose rappelle de
vaccins bivalents ça va les protéger
beaucoup mieux contre une infection
sévère avec ce nouveau variant là qui
circule et un mot qui est important là
que vous avez prononcé les gens
vulnérables mais les gens en santé
doivent attendre combien de temps avant
d'aller rechercher une autre dose
en fait on devrait aller chercher cette
dose de rappel à un intervalle de 5 mois
d'avoir reçu sa dernière dose de vaccin
et si on a fait la covid on doit
attendre trois mois avant d'aller
chercher sa dose de rappel mais pourquoi
j'insiste sur les gens plus vulnérables
ce sont eux qui risquent le plus d'avoir
une maladie grave de se rendre à
l'hôpital ou même dans des CD on
rappelle qu'il y a encore beaucoup de
décès dû à la covid présentement bien
qu'on en parle pas beaucoup
mais donc c'est ces gens-là qu'on veut
protéger mais les gens en bonne santé
doivent aussi recevoir leurs doses de
rappel pour être se protéger eux-mêmes
mais aussi protéger leur entourage parmi
lesquels il y a sûrement des personnes
âgées puis des gens vulnérables j'ai le
temps de vous poser une question sur une
nouvelle situation depuis minuit les
voyageurs en provenance de la Chine de
Macao de Hong Kong doivent fournir un
test négatif avant de monter à bord d'un
avion en direction du Canada est-ce que
vous trouvez que c'est un test qui est
suffisant c'est une bonne idée d'avoir
fait ça
en fait ça nous permet de gagner du
temps parce que ce que l'on craint avant
tout c'est qu'il y a des nouveaux
variants différents de ceux qu'on
connaît déjà qui émergent de Chine parce
que la multiplication est tellement
importante alors plus un virus se
multiplie plus il y a des chances de
muter et donc de générer un nouveau
variable étant donné que les
informations que l'on reçoit de Chine
sont très très parcellaires on ne
connaît pas exactement quelle variant
circule on sait que en général ce sont
les mêmes variants qui circulent ici en
Amérique du Nord mais on n'a pas
l'information totale alors en empêchant
des gens infectés d'arriver au Canada on
essaie de gagner du temps par rapport à
l'identification de ces nouveaux
variants là mais la réalité c'est que la
transmission de la covid est locale au
Canada au Québec en masse de covid qui
circule c'est pas parce que une ou deux
personnes arrivant de Chine ayant la
covid que ça va changer grand chose à
notre épidémie ça va changer quelque
chose s'ils amènent des nouveaux
variants qui échappent complètement
notre système immunitaire et c'est ça
qu'on veut éviter bon alors pas de
panique pour le X X BB 1.5 mais on se
fait vacciner absolument c'est le
Tremblay je rappelle que vous êtes
microbiologiste affectueux au centre
hospitalier de Montréal merci beaucoup
d'avoir été avec nous
ça me fait plaisir au revoir pour voir
nos émissions en entier rendez-vous sur
la chaîne ici RDI
[Musique]